The Legend of Tarzan took over a
Hollywood Boulevard for their big
premiere so it's good to be Tarzan to
the stars made out of the jungle but
while surviving the red carpet heat fete
is a whole other story
our Harley Steele was there I feel like
I'm in the jungle you are wearing kimono
yeah fern yeah pink fur cuffs the
temperature of boiling 95 degrees but
that didn't stop Margo from busting out
the peacock themed kimono by Gucci
feeling a little toasty no I not warm at
all not absolutely sweating no no good
she's such a good actress the Hollywood
Heat sort of like the jungle where
Tarzan swings from Vine Alexander
Skarsgard was positively ripped in his
shirtless scenes his diet was brutal the
portions were very small so I was
constantly hungry I finished my lunch
and I'd be like okay
2 hours and 55 minutes of my name's to
me oh is that why you do this smoldering
looks so much because you're just in a
bad mood to hold a hamburger behind the
camera like this and I go like I don't
possess the self-discipline or
self-control
to do what he did and Alexander tells us
as diet inspired his famous Tarzan call
my trainer was like you're gonna get
pasta for lunch and then I'd opened the
box and it be broccoli and then they
were recorded that you do as well I know
you've got a good one in there I know
you are Sam Jackson he will provide you
with the Tarzan calls
actually was pretty good like rock it
out